freunde vielleicht erinnert ihr euch an
eine lange vergangene zeit in der ich
einfach hier saß und essen bestellt habe
da wollen wir heute wieder hin aber es
wird nicht ganz so einfach wie damals
denn wir testen heute luxus zu schießen
und während man wahrscheinlich sagen
könntet das sushi immer luxus ist weil
es ja sowieso schon ein bisschen gehoben
ist und bis man sagt das muss man ein
paar sachen bestellen testen wir heute
wirklich die creme de la creme des
schieß ich zeige euch nämlich mal was
ich gefunden habe und zwar habe ich
diese instagram seid ihr entdeckt kaum
in so vielen ausfällt und ich sage euch
so viel wenn wir mal ein paar bilder
anklicken
wir sehen außergewöhnliche kreationen
und ich dachte mir da fährst du mal
hinter dem video machte restaurants ist
aber ich kann ja nicht hinfahren und
restaurants ist machen es ist nämlich
ein ausschließliches liefer konzept es
gibt keinen laden den man sich
reinsetzen kann und diese kreation
probieren kann nichtsdestotrotz wir
sehen hier sachen mit popcorn wir sehen
social kreationen mit trüffel also
wirklich verrückt sachen musste ich
einfach einem video probieren damit ihr
auch daran teilhaben können und das gute
ist ich bin hier im büro auch die jungs
dürfen alle probieren ich habe nämlich
eine richtig dicke bestellung
abgeschickt und dann war es auch schon
soweit unser sozis ankommen ihr seht ihr
die sushi boxen und wir packen das ganze
jetzt gemeinsam aus gebt euch bitte was
sich hier drin befindet
[Musik]
alter leute ist das noch essen oder ist
das schon kunst also ich kann wirklich
ohne mit der wimper zu zucken das mit
sternegastronomie vergleichen diese
kreativität diese farben mit denen
gespielt wird kontrast da werden noch
essbare blumen dazu bewegt es ist
wirklich will kann man nicht anders
sagen oder siehst du das dann ab ich
habe mich gar nicht mehr zügeln sah ich
das ist das ist wirklich als würdest du
den bild angucken ja das ist kunst es
ist crazy und wenn das halb so gut
schmeckt wie das aussieht dann werden
wir hier möglich rausgehen ecken hier so
rother reist mit sesam spinat sweet
susie dessert rollen wir gehen natürlich
gleich beim probieren auch alles einzeln
einen dampf links jedermann heute aber
auch nicht einfach so mit langweiligen
kein salz sondern hier auch mit so viel
mehr salz besser bitte lassen wir
darüber sprechen also erstens diese
portion hier reicht für vier erwachsene
männer länder ja aber mehr vier
erwachsene männer und das sollte sie
auch wenn man sich das preisschild an
die sag mal bitte was ihr schätzt was
wärt ihr bereit dafür zu bezahlen mir
vorstellen sonntagabend über irgendwie
mit eurer freunde mit eurer frau einen
schönen abend begehen bestellt euch das
für zwei personen was würdet ihr
bezahlen so gut und so schnell muss
natürlich auch gute soßen essen und
natürlich ebenfalls in
wiederverwendbaren glas schälchen
generell muss man sagen alles papier
karton kein plastik und ja mir
verschiedene einfach so
glasbehälter also wo krieg machen
was ist für männer ist klar aber das
finde ich auch wirklich genial einfach
eine ordentliche portion sojasauce
das was hier steht kostet 192 euro ist
auf jeden fall eine fette hausnummer und
wirklich den namen luxus wert aber ist
es das auch geschmacklich wird das
werden jetzt probieren
irgendwann muss man anfangen und das
darf dass das muss ich jetzt essen was
and movie night diese wollen wirklich
ehrlich ja wegen wegen der
popkultur natalie so mario tempura
süßkartoffel mit pop kompetenz
also das ist auch einfach kreativ ja
super kreative rolle auch und ganz neuer
ansatz für das einfach mal so ganz
anders zu nennen wie alle anderen hat
aber halt auch wahrscheinlich überhaupt
nichts mit traditionellen so viel zu tun
im jahr fahren sowieso ein
traditionelles social service
wahrscheinlich das wirkt oder vielleicht
noch gefeiert
salziges oder süßes popcorn selbst seit
ich oder wie sich aber in den
gesamtkontext es ist sich auf jeden fall
macht aber so als ente süß akzente leute
merkten wie so meine stimme direkt
gewählt wird von dieser mario
die süßkartoffel mario gibt cremigkeit
cracks abstrus cruz lachs mit gurke
hauchdünner abocard ob mit margaret
thatcher dressing schon wieder
fit
diese säure von jimmy choo dressing wird
dann so von der melde- und der avocado
abgefangen man selbst ja aber auch
teurer
zu machen
kannst vielleicht genug für alle da so
keine sorge ich und auch nicht was ich
jetzt machen so weiter es ist so viel
das kann ich gar nicht ausprobiert ist
eine kranke reizüberflutung doch
sämtliche
und ingwer
zwischenfazit krank nur neue
geschmackskombinationen nur hübsch
anzuschauen die komposition ist ganz
wichtig noch ganz wichtig hierbei zum
ski mit trüffel das hat mir auch zu den
letzten stoß gegeben das ganze hier
luxus so ski zu nennen das ist verrückt
frisch probe statt triple auf sushi dass
du nach hause geliefert also kann es mir
noch nicht vorstellen sagt so ganz
ehrlich wie
[Musik]
funktioniert das frischen geschmack gar
keine super dominante trüffel note sie
kommt er so hinten aus ist nicht so
dieses krasse künstliche aroma- und das
kranke ist als auch in der tat in
diese rolle hier nebendran eternal flame
heißt die hat einfach play - und ob die
gibt's hier nicht machen die importieren
die wahrscheinlich also das sind diese
roten dinger für die leute die die es
nicht kennten kinos tempura kanäle mario
keine überflutung oder oder man sieht
sie kaum an diese hätten sich so auf den
letzten metern da kommt dann so dieser
dieser klasse das stativ dass man dieser
clips geschmacks und dieses mäßiges
kommt an so ein ende auch dazu so dieser
spies von den schon in sotschi natürlich
müssen die jungs fragen jungs kommen auf
mehr
das ist leer
welche rolle würdest du dir jetzt
anschauen und welche rolle richtig am
meisten an jetzt ich sage ganz ehrlich
die standardmäßig
langweilig immer nur marquis smileys
oder nicht
ja weil das für mich dass brüste und das
leckerste an sushi es gibt dann bist du
das hier nicht würdig
aber ich werde das noch enorm ist das
ist dann in die rundschau
ich anfangen soll deine lieblings ein
kanal
wasser wieder keine punkte edle muss
dazu sagen die sind auch richtig gut
gefühlt also ich finde dass der ton für
stadt so ne geile farbe
ob es noch nicht so gut
[Musik]
leute meint steigert ist auch wirklich
ich kann nicht alles zeigen zum einen
weil ich nicht weiß was alles ist das
ist so crazy at&s hat so ein bisschen
was wenn man so wie wir einfach nur ein
paar worte durch bestellt hat ein
bisschen was von jelly beans so ist das
so dann bist du
[Musik]
burke war super rauchen schärfe zu
doch qualitätsmerkmal die stäbchen sind
manchmal wenn wir so es muss jetzt den
ressorts
zur
übels scharf
so superschnell und übelst voll
warum hat keiner diese rollen ja der
fläche wird zu sagen ist so vom anspruch
her du kommst hier alle an welche sagt
die am meisten zugelegt haben oder die
sich länger mit der schrift die
eigentlich probieren was ist das für ein
fisch ich glaube das ist ein heller
das ding es alle sachen sind crazy vom
geschmack hat man so noch nie gegessen
man schmeckt man weiß man merkt höchste
qualität aber es ist auch eine andere
kategorie als standard sushi das ist
eine sache wenn ich so in meinem kopf
sagt ja ich habe übels bock auf so
schied man habe ich nicht zwangsläufig
übels bock auf das sushi ich habe da
übels bock drauf weil das krank geiles
aber es ist halt was neues was anderes
so das ist so verrückt das ist auch und
viel aktiveres essen wieder so ein
erlebnis so ein happening einfach so das
ist ja auch klar so das ist nicht jeden
abend weil ich ja nicht zu sagen darf
scheiße ich habe auch schon mein
lieblingsrestaurant gezeigt und ich sehe
das gar nicht als konkurrenz dazu das
ist einfach etwas anderes das ist
einfach kunst so zum schmecken und zum
sehen die nach hause bestellen können ja
dass es zur fusion sheen ja auch das ist
so dass wir hier drin ist rindert hat ja
es ist so konzept zu schicken da man
sich so hin gedacht gesagt was packen
wir zusammen was scheinbar nicht
zusammen gehört aber trotzdem gut
funktioniert es ist für mich wirklich
sterne so scheer also einfach neu
gedacht ist kreatives geiles
interessantes sushi eine sache muss sich
aber zum zum ende verlieren seht ihr das
mit was das so charmant ist das ist
drachenfrucht seht ihr das hier gefüllt
mit einer himbeere obendrauf eine blume
und machten mit drachen braucht das
wirklich suzuki neu gedacht oh
mein gott
das haben wir jetzt ein paar am meisten
geflecht von allem
behämmert irgendwie schmeckt ersten
garten ja die jetzt so dir so richtig ob
das hat nicht mal den hauch von
leichtigkeit und das ist wirklich eine
rundum geil ist es her und ist sushi
rolle würde ich gar nichts mehr ich
breche ab ich weiß gar nicht was ich
sagen soll ich erlebt habe ich nur noch
krasse sachen kulinarischen fliegt immer
nur noch kraft hat leute wir haben das
nicht mal halb aufgegessen und ich bin
so sagt jetzt unglaublich ich habe
eigentlich alles dazu schon gesagt ist
ein erlebnis das ist wunderschön ihr
habt selbst gesehen also ich glaube man
bekommt auch lust das selbst zu
probieren aber wie gesagt es ist nicht
das beste sushi was hier gegessen habe
es ist ein wahnsinnig gutes sushi ist es
ein ganz anderes wenn ihr die
gelegenheit habt probiert auf jeden fall
mal aus crazy es war wirklich mal
erfrischend nach den ganzen guten
restaurants in den wert war einfach mal
zu hause zu ziehen und diese qualität
geliefert zu bekommen dank fürs zu sehen
ich sage so viel das nächste video
startet eine neue ära wir verlassen den
kontinent sage mal so viel bis dahin
[Musik]